من بدايه مسار الزلزال وعمليات البحث
والانقاذ مستمره والبحث عن المفقودين ما
خلص واللي من بينهم لاعب كره القدم
كريستيانو البالغ من العمر 31 سنه واللي
كان متواجد في تركيا يوم حدوث الزلزال
كريستيانو لاعب سابق لصالح عدد من النوادي
مثل النادي نيوكاسل بورنو تشيلسي ولعب حتى
مع منتخب بلاده وغانا ما يزيد عن 52
مباراه وشارك في كاس العالم عام 2014
ولكنه كان غايب عن مونديال قطر في 2020
وكريستيان كان ينتقل في سبتمبر الماضي من
نادي الرائد السعودي لنادي هاتاي سبورت
اللي كان محطته الاخيره لانه للاسف امس تم
الاعلان عن العثور على جثته تحت الانقاض
في تركيا وتم نقل جثمان اليوم من مطار
اضنه الى غانا
كل قصص الوفاه وخسائر الزلزال محزنه جدا
لكن قصه فيها كم من المفارقات واللحظات
الفاصله بين الحياه والموت اللي حقيقه
مؤثره جدا فاللاعب كان عنده طياره بعد
الزلزال بيوم حاجزها للسفر من اسطنبول
لفرنسا بحثا عن نادي جديد لانه كان مستاء
انه خلال الموسم كله ما لعب معه فريقه
باس لكن وقبل الزلزال بيوم فريقه كان عنده
مباراه مهمه والمباراه فضلت نتيجتها سلبيه
حتى الدقيقه 82 وعندها المدرب دخل ويلعب
والحكم حسب سبع دقائق وقت بدل ضايع وفي
اخر دقيقه سجل اتسو هدف وفاز فريقه
بالمباراه ولما شاف كده اجل سفره ثاني يوم
علشان يحتفل مع زملائه بالف هدف والفوز
دون ان يدري انه هذا كان اخر هدف في حياته
فمن سته فبراير وقت الزلزال اعلن انه
مفقود ومن بعدها في 14 فبراير لقيو حذاء
وبين انقاض المجمع السكني الفاخر اللي
بيسكن فيه فيها تاي واللي انهار مثل احجار
الدومينو في الزلزال ومن بعد ايام من
البحث جواله تحت الركام وامس من بعد 12
يوم لقيو جثه تحت الانقاض وقالت وزاره
الخارجيه انه شقيقه واخته التوام كانوا
موجودين وقت لما نطلعوا الجثه من تحت
الانقاض
وكنوع من الحداد على روحه قبل بدايه
مباراه نيوكاسل وليفربول في الدوري
الانجليزي اللي اقيمت امس على ارض ملعب
سين جيمس بارك كان في دقيقه صمت حداد على
وفاه كريستيانو وكان من بين الحضور ارمله
وطفله في المدرجات واللي ارتدوا خلال
المباراه قميص نيوكاسل وظهرت تاثر زوجته
اللي غلبها او غلبتها دموعها خلال التصفيق
لزوجها الراحل وفي البرتغال كمان في
مباراه بين فريقين محليين رفع اللاعبين
قمصان عليها اسم اللاعب الراحل قبل بدء
مباراههم تكريما له